okay welcome to this talk about
clojurescript the very last session on
nbc2 2021
so thank you for
showing up and for tuning in if you're
tuning in online
so
this talk will be i'll
show you uh the closure script
programming language and
what it's like developing with it so
it's a closed grip is a functional
programming language that compiles to
javascript
and it has a bunch of really excellent
tools for front-end web development
and
it has a quite unique development
um
development environment that's very very
dynamic and interactive
and the goal this talk is to show you
what it's like working with us
so i don't have any slides i just have
my text editor you see on screen now so
i'll be writing some code trying to
explain some basic features of the
language and show you the tools that you
have available to work with
yes my name is christine johnson i work
for cool markers as a consultancy here
in town
and for the past four years i've worked
full time with clojurescript and clojure
and then
i've done a lot of closure script also
prior to that all the way back to 2013.
so let's get started so
i'll start by just taking a quick look
at the language and the best way to
introduce the language i find is to look
at its data structures
so it compiles the javascript and it
runs in a javascript environment
and
so it uses
it uses javascript where it can so
numbers in cloud descript are javascript
numbers there's nothing special about
them
same thing with strings
strings are also just javascript strings
things start to look different when you
want to call functions
so in like in javascript you could
imagine doing something like this you
call inc to increment the number
and in closure script this looks very
different because the parentheses goes
from the beginning
and
closed could actually does this for a
very very good reason that i will
explain shortly but i can evaluate this
so anytime you see this on the screen
the arrow pointing that's me eval
evaluating the code and getting an
answer back so ink increments the number
by one cool i can call functions on
strings as well
so let's see we can do
repeat
three
and if i evaluate that i get a list of
three strings repeated one after another
okay
there are more data types here if we
have booleans of course and then we have
this thing here which looks like in
javascript array except it's called a
vector enclosure script but it works the
same way it's an indexed data structure
you can add things to the end of it
and then we of course saw let me just
copy this one
we saw this other kind of list that we
got before
and you have sets which are unordered
sets of collections of items that
enforces unique entries
inside
and then i will show you two more things
so
this thing here is called a keyword and
a keyword is much like a string except
you would use it typically in technical
context so if you want to use it for a
key in a map
wherever you use strings in your code
basically including use
keywords instead
so
let's make a map then
this is a map has key value pairs
and you typically use you can use
strings for you can you use any value
for keys and maps but typically you use
keywords
so these are roughly
most of the data types that this
language has for you to work with
and there are a few interesting things
that we need to discuss here before we
move on
and the first one is that all of these
data types are immutable which means
that they cannot change so we already
know this is true from strings right
so if i have a string here and i call
to lowercase on it
then that gives me a new string it
doesn't ruin my old string right the old
one is still the uppercase string and
the new one is the lowercase strings so
colorscape does the same for all these
data types so if i call this
structure here
numbers i have the numbers and i can do
conj which
adds to the end of the list
now i have a list of one two three four
five six but the old list still only has
one two three four five so this enables
us to write functional code
all these data types are immutable
okay very good another thing that's
interesting
is that
if you take a look at this list here
this has the exact same appearance as
the function call
that created it right
and the reason for this is that
clojurescript code which this is
is cladoscript data
so the language is built up of its own
data structures and in fact
all the syntax in the language
or roughly all of it maybe 95 are
already covered on this slide this is
all the syntax the language has
it just uses these data types in
different orderings to create other
structures so if i want to do an if
that's a parenthesis it's a list
and then you have an expression here
and then you have the true part and the
false part and what about this one is
that an operator no it's not an operator
it's a function
so anything that typically in other
languages are operators are functions
okay
but how come this is a function call and
this is data
well that just
it's up to how you evaluate it so when
you evaluate it in the context of a
program clone descript expects the first
thing in the list to be a function that
it calls with the other arguments
so if i try to evaluate this one i get
the list but if i evaluate this one i
get an error because
strings are not functions so i can't
call it
but if i put a quotation mark in front
of it i can evaluate it as literal data
and you can do the same thing
with code
so now i just get a list back
with a symbol a number and a string and
you can you can even manipulate the code
as if it were data so i could say filter
number and then i get back all the
pieces of code that was a number
this is pretty cool and
this is what you use to create macros
which is code that generates code i'm
not going to talk a lot about that today
but it's an interesting
aspect of the language a more practical
aspect of this is that
because
all the code is data we can approach it
when we
work with it in a little bit different
manner
so i'll show you this by creating a
function i'll call it magnify
and it's going to magnify a number into
on the undefined manner
okay
so i can call this now this way and it
doubles the number
so again we have just a bunch of data so
you can look at the code as a tree
basically
and
my editor can then use
structural commands to navigate the code
so now if i hit down i go into the list
and i can go forward forward
forward or back and then down again to
go into this list
and you can really think about your code
in a much more structured manner than
you are probably used to and if i go up
up i get back up to the top
so that's navigation but editing is even
more interesting so let's say that i
want to treat negative numbers
differently
well i will have need to have an if
and then i say if it's positive oh sorry
if it's positive now i want this thing
to be my if part and something else
would be the else part
i could cop it and move it to the right
place or i could just use the command
slurp
which moves the next expression into the
one i'm inside
and then we could have a separate case
for negative numbers this is obviously
just a silly function
[Music]
yeah there we go and then maybe i regret
this and i just want i only need this in
my implementation
then i can perform the command raise
which makes this expression take the
place of its surrounding expression
right
so it's inside an expression and i lift
it up and this is actually very very
useful when you edit code
so in this mode of editing it's also
impossible to delete characters that
would unbalance your tree so i this i'm
hitting backspace here now i cannot
delete these parentheses because it does
not make any sense
i can only delete them when i delete the
entire expression
okay
so i've been evaluating this and running
this and i said that closures group
compiles to javascript so where
is this running it needs to run in a
javascript environment right
well right now it's running inside emacs
but emacs is talking to the outsold side
world to make this happen so
let's see if i do js slash i can access
the javascript global namespace so
anything that's available in javascript
is available on the jslash so if i type
alert i can say hello
and now firefox starts jumping because
there's an alert box over in my browser
here
and you can even see
my exception from before over in the
dev tools here
so this is the browser that's running my
code and this browser we will work with
for the rest of this presentation so let
me just do this
is is it readable
fonts
not the browser
uh
yeah
cool
okay
so
we have the browser and we have a live
environment inside our editor let's
start to build something
so
the code that we did before i'm going to
stick inside something called a comment
which looks like this
and
what this does
is that
it allows me to keep the code here if i
want to evaluate it to test things out
but when closing compiles this file it's
just going to remove the whole thing
so if you load this file in the browser
nothing's going to happen but i have it
available
to play around with if i want to test
functions in my namespace or whatever
so we'll just keep that here and now to
render something on screen i will pull
down a library
which is called dum-dum
and dum-dum is a component library that
works similar to how react works
you can define uh components that define
the markup of your page and the library
makes sure that the dom has the same
structure
and it does so in an efficient manner
and because colorscript has immutable
data structures it can really make that
diffing operation very efficiently
so uh dim dome um
by the way i don't don't know if you can
see the bottom of my screen but towards
the bottom here i get uh
you see the
uh the signature of the function to help
me
work with it
so
the render takes a component and an
element to put it inside of so the
element i can get because i prepared it
before this talk so it's called get
element by id
app and to make sure that i remember
correctly i can evaluate this
and yes that's a development
and then the smallest component i can
make looks like this
so if i evaluate this now i get some
text on screen over here
so what's this
again this is just closer script data
right it's just a vector with a keyword
and a string
so it's all data the code is data the
markup is data everything's data
in the clojure enclosure script
community this kind of data is
colloquially referred to as hiccup
but
it's really just vectors with keywords
and strings inside
if i put a dot i can add a class name to
it which will trigger my
pre-made css which makes the text a
little bit bigger
you can add attributes style
color
red
and then it turns red
okay
so i'm going to now
try to build something a little bit
bigger so we need to have some data
and then we need to have um
i need to put this in a function okay
render it will take some data in
and we'll take a look at this later okay
so our data
so
um
i prepared a small example to build and
then i figured uh
the most common example to build is like
a to-do list and i figured i'll i'm
gonna in
be very creative so i created a shopping
list instead
[Applause]
uh i yeah i could have chosen something
more fun i guess but i wanted an example
that it's correct likely
manipulated because it's similar to what
we you typically do in our day jobs so
that's why i chose that
anyway so i'll define a store the store
is my global
storage of data in the whole application
that i'll have in the browser
and
in my first attempt it's going to be a
map
and inside i will have a shopping list
let's just imagine that we navigated to
a specific list
and it will be for a specific week and
it will have some groceries on it
which is a vector of items of i'll just
say text um
text
orange and then of course we also need
to have a kovit 19 test
now
because this map is immutable it's not
very suited for the global storage
because i
i can't update it right so my global
source needs to be something that can
update
so typically what we do is that we wrap
this in something called an atom and an
atom is like an object that only stores
one
one value
so typically you take an immutable value
and store it in an atom and then you can
exchange the value over time
but the advantage of this process is
that
95 of my code will see this immutable
value inside and will be functional call
working on immutable values
and then just the very top layer will
know anything about this mutable atom
that's on top
and then finally i'm going to change
from a depth to a def once because when
the browser reloads my code i don't want
to reload the data
so that's my data
and then
we can take a look at the
so i'm going to call this machinery so
i'm going to have a few pieces of code
here that would naturally go in
different files in production i'm just
going to annotate them with comments and
keep them in the same place for now
so
we need ui components
so now we are going to uh so previously
i created some hiccup markup just in
line in the render call now i want to
create a reusable component
and oh to do that we're going to prefer
something called a def component
which just allows me to define a
component that i can use over and over
again so we'll call list page component
and it will receive some kind of data
and i'll move this markup into the
component here
and then inside the render function
we'll call this component with the data
that's being passed to render
and then finally
i'll have a small boot up section to the
bottom here
where we call the render once
with the contents of the store so this
app picks out the map that's inside the
store
and then i can add a watch
to the store
that will call this function every time
the contents change
so i don't really have time to explain
all the arguments all the details of
this but uh so this is a subscription
for changes to the store and it will
call render as well
so
with that i have my little world up and
going
so no changes on the screen because the
component still just does
static data
so let's use some of the data we're
getting in here to render
now inside this component this is a ui
component i don't really want the ui
component to be talking about shopping
lists and groceries and weeks
i would much rather just said
title
and then someone else is going to have
to prepare that for me so the reason for
this i will explain in a little moment
but for now i'm going to put a function
that is called prepare ui data
that we will create
and its job is to not be machinery but
to be something much more important this
is our business logic
so the business logic is
responsible for taking our
business domain data and turning it into
ui data
so by making this very clear separation
i can have all my important testable
logic in just pure functions that take
immutable data in and return immutable
data out
and this way i can write lots of tests
for the important bits and i don't have
to write tests that trigger the ui
specifically i'll show another way to
test the ui specifically in a little bit
anyway it's going to generate a title
that it's just going to be string week
and then
the week
number
uh let's just say this week okay
i'm going to call this not data but
state
these are words that i made up that i
use in my daily work so we call
like the main store is the store that's
the mutable thing that contains the data
and the thing that's inside it the the
snapshot that's the state
and then the components work on just uh
ui data of some sort
okay so this functional receives the
state and returns a title
and then it says weeks something and
then there's no week because
i have to get the week from the shopping
list so state
shopping list week
this is week 45. let's get rid of that
red color
okay and then i also just to make it put
some colors on screen i prepared another
component that we can use
which is called a list icon
and we have to import it and that looks
like
that's a very very big list icon
um okay i can theme it
to pink and then we can put it inside
something that makes it a little bit
smaller
64 pixels is about right
and then we can put some styles here
we can say display flex
uh that should put them on side by side
and then it's align something items
maybe i don't know center
and then we can put some margins on it
and you can see that the browser just
keeps updating as i save my file
so previously i was going around
evaluating a lot of code but now i'm
just saving file and having it auto
update so
the good thing about the saving part is
that it will evaluate all the code at
once but sometimes you only want to
evaluate a little bit but you have the
option to choose which one fits
in a given situation
okay uh i put a mod
mar gin
and then we want to space that header a
little bit
so we'll give it a left margin as well
okay and now we have a nice header
then i'm going to create a
some more margins
20 and then inside here we will have our
list
and okay so now i can use i'm going to
use a for loop which loops through all
the items of a collection but then i
have to have a collection which i don't
at this point
so my prepare function needs to prepare
more data
items
so sufficiently
meaningless term
so we'll grab the state shopping list
groceries and that's a list if you
remember of things with text which is
sufficiently good for the ui
i just want to avoid mainly that i have
ui
or sorry domain concepts inside my ui
components because that really makes
them not so reusable for different
contexts
so i didn't finish the code here and
that's what the compiler telling me over
here
so we have
i can destructure
the text from the items
in my ui data
li text so this is going a little bit
okay
i'm doing this quickly but
my goal as i said is to give you the
feel of this environment
so i don't want the items
in my flex over here
so again i'll create a div here and i'll
do slurp to move everything inside it
and i'll go into this one and i can spit
out the last element that i did not want
in my header
then i get it positioned here
okay
so
now we're about to get to something
interesting because now i want to create
my um
input field where i can type new things
to add to the list
and since this is a shopping list i'll
be typing the same things in here week
after week
would be very good to have some sort of
completion help
type completion right
so i want to create a somewhat
intelligent
thing at the top here
that can complete things for me so i'll
create that as a separate component def
component
and i'll call it completion input
and my first version of this is just
going to be the input element with the
input class
and then let's see
i can go
we'll okay
lots of margin 20 and then we'll put it
here completion input and some data i
don't know what the data is yet
that gives me an input but it doesn't do
anything
so
let's think about the different cases we
have for this i
when there's nothing here i want to have
a placeholder of some sort and then if
there's text inside i want the text to
be brighter than the placeholder and if
you're typing and we have good
suggestions we want to display them
somehow
that means that this ui control can have
many visual states but you can only ever
see one at a time
so
to solve this problem i will use a tool
called dev cards
which looks like this
so i created one example up front which
just renders that list icon a bunch of
times to test out different color
pallets
so what this thing here does is it
actually doesn't do a lot
it just enables you to render out a
component many times with different data
such as you can see many versions
in one go
it's kind of like unit tests for your
visual design except they're not
automated because it's hard to automate
visual
properties
so i'll
put this in a separate file for now
we'll call it a completion
input
and then we're going to create
okay
require um
[Music]
and then dev cars is a separate library
but it's it comes with built-in support
for react components so dum dum has a
wrapper for it
that teaches it to understand
its components
and it has a thing called def card so
the way it works is like this you create
an example of using your component so i
can say basic input is
looks like this
and now i will just have to put this on
the list of available dev cards which i
have here
and then we'll
go here
okay
so here we go i have now have one
example of using this component
now
i can add some more examples let's say i
want to have an input with placeholder
so that means that i'll pass in the
placeholder
type something
basically this is like test driven
development except for just the visual
part of the wrap so
this looks exactly the same because i'm
not really doing anything in this
component here so let's
destructure the data that's coming in
and then we'll pass it on
and now i have a placeholder okay it
looks good let's create another example
with value
perhaps
value
banana
and then it still just shows the
placeholder because i'm not using the
value for anything
i could also just pass the data down to
the input but i have a feeling that
we'll
not want to pass everything along so
okay banana good
and then if i focus it it looks a little
bit different i could have made a card
that auto put automatically put the
focus on but you still have to have
focus on the browser window so it's not
of that much help
but anyway i've increased my my
bandwidth now because i can see three
versions of the component in one go and
i don't have to think about
what my app is doing to create it
so let's hash out the completion bit
so now i want to have an input with a
completion
so
scratch the placeholder and then i say
completion i need to have a partial word
here
i have another word
or
and then it says orange
so
now i want this to kind of fill out in
the back background so that you can hit
tab or whatever to complete it
one way to do this is to render two
separate input fields so let's do that
so now we have a completion here or
rather we may have a completion
so
i'll create a wrapper element and then
i'll say when there is a completion
render another input
and its value will be
the completion
okay now i have two inputs
if i want them to look like they're
completing each other they need to be on
top of each other so
let's put some
relative positioning on the outer
element
position
relative
and now if i do style
position
absolute on this one
something ridiculous is going to happen
so
now my final element looks closer to
what i want but all the others collapsed
because
when this is
absolutely positioned
then the div will collapse if it doesn't
have any other content so
that means that
i'm going to put this
here and then we're only going to do
this when we have a completion
okay so now you can see that in my
completion card
the field is to the right here so i want
it to sit on top
and the way to do that is just to glue
it to all the sides
and this is going to work because the
two elements are the exact same element
and the div is now going to be shaped
like this one
so if i position the other one to all
the edges it's going to perfectly
overlap the underlying input
but now it's also covering it up so i
can't see it
but that can be easily fixed by setting
the background on the
top input field to transparent
and then boom
it looks like i have a suggestion right
so this is just a visual part i still
have to figure out like where does the
completions come from and how do i get
them into my app and and so on and so
forth but now i'm focusing on the
front-end bit
i want to create one more example
and i want i want to see how this what
this feel like if the suggestion is
popping up as i type
so to do that
i will have a input with live completion
so if i pass a function instead of a
component to this def card thing
then it's going to create an atom for me
and pass it to the function and i can
read from the atom to render and i can
use an event handler to update the item
and then dev carts will re-render the
card
so
okay i'll pick out the value from the
store
and then we don't have any completions
for now
and if i want i can also feed it some
initial data so i could say the initial
value is
i don't know pizza
and then maybe we also need to have some
completions to pick from later
so bandana
bazooka and
bajunga okay
new car at the bottom it renders with
pizza because i said that was the
initial value
but really i want now as i type to
update the store
so that means we need an event handler
on input
which will receive an event
and then i can update the atom by
calling swap
associate
value and
i'll explain this in a moment target
value
okay so this last thing here dot dot
just means
perform operations on this thing
so this is the event get the target and
get the value from that
and the other stuff here swap swaps out
the contents of the store
and really give you can give it a
function it will pass the value into the
function and then you can do stuff with
it and then it has a shorthand for
let me just show you
swap store fn
state assoc state
so these two are the same so this is
just a uh
impenetrable shortcut if you don't know
the language from before
but trust me this does what it says it
does
so at least now as i type
i should be able to update the text
field because we're setting the value
now i can choose a completion
by looking at
completions in store
and then i can filter them
so i'll pass the completions to filter
completion uh screw that we're going to
do inline and then i'll say
starts
with and then this is the argument
that's being passed the filter
and then
this is the value
[Music]
i'll try to save a little bit of space
okay so if the completion starts with
the string that i'm typing
and then i want the first one
so
nothing happens
okay
we'll figure out why
anyway um let's take a look what's going
on here so we have
our completions
and yeah okay so what's going on is that
we have this input handler here that's
not being used at all by our component
so nothing is going on
um
so we need to take it in here and then
just pass it along to the input field
and now i can try it again we type and
then it suggests something and now you
kind of get the feeling of getting
suggestions
and i immediately said it's making
suggestions when it's empty which is not
really good but that's not inside the ui
component so it's not really that big of
a problem but i can do one not empty
v
that way i don't get suggestions for
empty text
okay so now i have hashed out all the
visual states of my component
i can go back to my application and
render it
and then later i can figure out where is
this data going to come from when will i
have to contact the server to get it
that's a separate concern
um yeah and then i need to comment
something because now i'm putting what
is basically a bunch of tests into my
implementation
would you do this in production you
could
and here's the reason so def card here
is a macro
and it has a
configuration option that you can flip
when you compile
and if you turn it off it just gets
compiled right out
so you can compile for production and
still keep the card in your source file
or if you don't like it you can put it
in a separate file and just don't
include it in the build at all so that's
a bit of
comes down to your preferences but for
demonstration purposes it's very helpful
to have them in the same file
yes
okay
let's try and go and get back to our app
and then um i don't need to have that
here because we
have created in a separate file
and uh
we need some
parameters to send to it
okay
and
so
here we need to prepare some data to
pass to our completion input
so what will we pass well i have a
placeholder
ingredient or whatever
grocery
then i may have to
update here
and then nothing is happening still
because i'm not sending
input ui data here
okay so the placeholder now says
ingredient
just ignore that
but
i now needed to update the current value
so i know what the user is typing
because we will need that to find good
suggestions
and
to do that as you might remember from
the card i need to pass on input but
ah-ha
i don't want to put a function inside my
ui data i want the ui data to be
serializable simple data because then i
can
i can get the data prepared directly
from the server or i can store it on
disk and use it for
regression tests you can do so much
things if you just have pure data so
this functionality really poisons the
entire idea so i don't want to do that
but luckily i can put data on the event
handler as well
if you do
you can tell
dum
how to dispatch events global instead
so i'll say handle event here and then
it'll pass me the event
and
whatever data came from your event
handler
so this allows me to bypass needing a
function at this point
and i can get it down here instead and
then what we want to do is to handle
action is what i'm going to call this
and this function belongs close to my
data
because actions are about
manipulating the data we have in store
event data and my first implementation
will just print
the action that's coming in and then
here
we have to figure out what is this going
to look like and doomdum only passes the
data through it doesn't care what it is
you can put whatever you want in here
but i'm going to put a keyword that is
the name of an action which is to save
in store
and i want to save it in this key
and then
i would really like the value of the
input field here
but i would have to get that from the
event object which i don't have access
to here
okay
i don't that's not possible but i can
put a placeholder so i could say uh
event
of
target value this is also just a keyword
the slasher just makes it a namespace
keyword
but right now it's just a placeholder so
we'll have to figure out what to do with
this later
if i save it now
we should be able to type here
and then see the browser logging that
it's it's triggering this action right
so at least we know that it's working
um
in my handle action function i have
again the same thing that we did before
i have the value that you want
so let's see this again
the value is here right so i need to put
it inside here somewhere
so i'm going to show you a very cool
feature that ships are that ships with
the standard library enclosures
clojure script
which is called
walk
post walk
so you can pass
a data and a function to it
and then it's going to call this
function for every
thing inside this data it's just going
to walk the whole tree
and then give you each and every item
from
it goes depth first
and then if
if you want you can return something
else from the function and that will be
replaced in the structure
so basically if x is this keyword
then i want this value
otherwise i'll just take the x that was
there from before
so now we can print this instead and it
should look a little bit more relevant
um
it says save and store current ban
ah
cool so now i can access the value
and i did it all just completely data
driven there's no functions in here
which makes me happy
okay
so let's say let action
is this
and i probably still want to print it
just so we can see it for later
and then we can case on
first action which will be this keyword
here
and then we can have i can implement
multiple kinds of actions eventually
and this one will be implemented using
swap just like we did before swap
on the store that's up here
the store now becomes like
it does become
a global
thing
i could have passed it into this
function as well but i'll let it pass
for now
so what do i want to pass i want to pass
as search and then i want the rest of
the arguments from here
and i can do that by just doing apply
and then doing
rest action which skips the first one
and just gives you the rest
as a list
okay
oh i deleted my logging
feature
so
how can we know if this is working
well i have two options the first one is
simply to just go into my comment block
here
and then i can de-rough my store and
just look at it
yeah
looks like it's working
pretty good you could even do things
like i could just look it up directly
and yeah work with it however i want so
this is very useful but also
just being able to look at everything in
the store
is quite useful so i'll introduce yet
another library for this
this is more of a development tool that
you typically wouldn't put in production
code but
so it's called gadget inspector
and as the name implies it inspects
stuff
so
in our
boot up sequence to the bottom here
we'll call
gadget inspect
store and just pass it to store
now this library has a companion browser
extension
that i can find over here
gadget and
i'm sorry this text is very tiny
i'm not sure i can
yeah it doesn't really respond to my
keyboard either but
trust me you can see the data in here if
you're close enough to the screen and
not only can you see but you can click
around and navigate into the data
and this handles all kinds of data and
it's very easy to
you can add
code to let it navigate your custom data
structures and and whatever you want
so having this app on the side is very
useful
but we can make it even more useful if
we do it one more time so
in here we convert our store to ui data
i would be interested in having a look
at what that looks like as well so
we can go here and i can do
ui data
and then
like
so
and just before we render
gadget
inspect
ui data
so now
i have the store on top i'm sorry this
font is so small
and then i you have ui data below and
now every time i type here i can see how
things are changing
so it gets live updated over here in the
store but nothing is happening in the ui
data so that means that we have to go
into this business logic here
and put a value that reads the current
from store
and then if we click input here
it still says value nil
yes because it's called state not store
so now it says banana down here
um
cool
so
let's
stick
[Music]
okay let's do this i'll just do swap
store
search and then completion so we'll just
put some completions into
into the store
and then we'll take the ones from here
sorry but i don't have time to implement
the full server fetch right now so we'll
just work with some test data
but now we can see over here or
here if you will
that we have some completions in the
store now
so
in my business logic here
we can look for a completion
find completion and then i'll pass in
the completions that are in state and
my current
value and
find completion
takes completions and value and then
we're just going to rob the code from
our test here from before
this is very simplistic but hopefully
you kind of get the point
okay completions
so let's move this a little bit and then
if i type b
and now it's just banana to me
and then you can keep working on it make
it more intelligent and this is just
data it's just data in data out you can
write tests for it you can do all sorts
of things
and if you want to work on the ui
of side of things you can go over here
and focus solely on the ui so now you
have this really nice workflow that's
very it's very interactive
and you have tight focus on your ui
components and you have tight focus on
your business logic and you can separate
them very clearly and even the actions
that we talked about up here like this
one only puts stuff in the store but
other actions will inevitably
be more involved and then you can test
them as well
so i just want to show you one more
thing before i close up and that's
one more example of
such a dev card is what we have here
and this one i created before i came
and
for the items in the list it would be
very nice
if you could use like swipe gestures to
get rid of them
and that's
something that's quite
uh
quite
picky stuff to to create because you
have to put lots of uh event handlers on
it there's lots of
tedious maths and
you gotta find the right thresholds like
you want if you're gonna swipe it you
don't want it to slide too easily you
want to swipe just right
so being able to just focus on the
individual behaviors like here
is just insanely useful
and not having to worry about my login
session timing out or being in the right
place in the app or whatever and here we
can just create all the ludicrous
situations as you can imagine
and see them all in one go
so you can see here
this one for instance can be dragged
like uh left and it can be and it snaps
and it can snap back
you can drag to the right but you cannot
drag it to the right and then to the
left
lots of like tiny details just really
only about the visual part of the
application
and then the final example
here i have a big red one that covers
the entire item if i click it you can
see that it has a nice transition on it
and then we can put this under the
draggable and make sure that when it
hits a certain threshold we can trigger
the transition
and if you do that it can look like this
so you can see that once it gets
revealed it kind of
pops into view and if i drag it out to
the side
it goes away and then it comes back so i
can try it again so you can keep
iterating on it
so this kind of
tight feedback
is just incredibly useful so
yeah so we didn't get so far in this app
but you know it's 10 past five and a
friday afternoon
this is about what i have prepared i
hope you found it useful or at least
inspiring in some way and want to give
it a shot
it's great fun working with
so yeah thank you for listening
you